Sur l'aide médicale d'État,
qu'est-ce qu'on dit
du côté du du Rassemblement National,
il faut la supprimer,
ça coûte trop cher, évidemment,
il faut la supprimer
et la remplacer par 1 aide médicale d'urgence.
C'est-ce que propose le Rassemblement National
et Marine Le Pen
depuis plus de 15 ans,
vous avez pas entendu ce que je viens de dire, monsieur ?
Aujourd'hui, moi, je me félicite
que, euh. Certains, donc sur ce point, vous êtes ok,
euh.
Et et même certains dans la majorité présidentielle
nous disent qu'aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen avait raison,
grand bien à leur face.
Moi, je suis content
quand on nous dit que les propositions
que nous faisons depuis des années, sans les bonnes,
effectivement, euh, c'est 1 solution.
Je pense sincèrement que c'est 1 solution.
Ce que vous dites est faux,
mais en réalité, aujourd'hui, ils sont soignés
ces gens-là. Vous savez très bien,
l'aide médicale d'État sert également
à des soins de confort.
Nous, nous souhaitons qu'on travaille dessus, d'accord.
Utiliser que pour des soins vitaux,
on ne peut pas compliquer.
Donc vous nous dites aussi que l'am
E est aussi 1 appel d'air pour euh.
Bien sûr des étrangers.
Bien sûr, parce qu'aujourd'hui,
on sait très bien qu'un certain nombre
d'étrangers viennent sur le territoire français,
parce que nous sommes l'un des rares pays
dans le monde à euh.
Offrir ses soins de confiance.
Et est-ce qu'on ne s'honore pas justement,
la France nous a soigné ses étrangers en difficulté,
pas sur les soins de confort,
sur les. Soins vitaux,
évidemment, et personne ne dit l'inverse.
Et personne ne souvient quelqu'un.
Euh. Mourir sur le chemin, évidemment.
Excusez-moi,
mais excusez-moi, mais pourquoi vous parlez de 2 ?
Il faut pas oublier que 1 tiers des français
et est 1 sondage récent, là démontré,
1 tiers des Français ont renoncé ces dernières années à,
euh.
Certains soins parce qu'ils n'avaient pas les moyens.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut se regarder en face
en se disant que des français n'arrivent pas à se
soigner, mais par contre que l'on soigne des étrangers ?
1 mot sur la main.